ALEXA GRIFFITH: Hi, my
name is Alexa Griffith.
Yes, my name really is
Alexa, but hopefully I
won't echo today.
And I'm presenting with
my amazing [INAUDIBLE],,
Mike Hurwitz, who
we call Danger.
We're both Software Engineers on
the Data Science Infrastructure
Team at Bluecore,
and today, we're
going to talk about how we
use Google Cloud to serve
tens of thousands
of personalized
recommendations per second.
At Bluecore we have a saying,
"As simple as possible,
as powerful as necessary."
This is one of our
company values,
and we will keep this
in mind as we discuss
the evolution of building
our robust recommendation
service throughout this talk.
So GCP has enabled us
to build a service that
has this value of being
as simple as possible,
and as powerful as necessary.
In building the
recommendation service,
we're able to leverage the
wide variety of GCP tools
to store, query, and serve data.
They all [INAUDIBLE]
some purpose,
but really, it's the
breadth of their offerings
that makes services like
ours possible, while allowing
us to maintain a low
operational overhead.
So you might be wondering,
what is Bluecore?
Bluecore offers intelligent
e-commerce marketing
as a service.
We send you marketing
emails that don't suck,
and we aim to send you
better emails, not more.
We're a company that's
around 7 years old.
We have around 250 employees.
We serve hundreds
of large retailers,
including some you
may have heard of,
like Nike and Sephora.
What makes us different is that
we don't send the same email
to every person.
Almost all of our millions of
emails that we send every day
are personalized.
Additionally, we've
started providing
real-time recommendations
on retailers' websites.
And we're going to refer to
this as our on-site product.
So let's discuss.
What even is a recommendation?
Well, when we talk
about a recommendation,
we're talking about
products that we
think someone will like based
on either a product they've
interacted with, or they
may have a preference for,
given their purchase and
viewing history in the past.
Essentially, we map either
an email or a product
ID to a list of
recommended products.
For example, in these
cases, two recipients
of the same campaign, which is
just the type of email send,
left different items
in their carts.
And we call these
"abandoned cart emails."
If we take a look at
the email on the left,
the person's left
jeans in their cart.
It's possible that, based
on their past purchasing
and viewing history,
we want to recommend
to them a cami or a t-shirt.
On the other hand,
in the right email,
a person has left a collared
shirt in their cart.
We may recommend other products
similar to the collared shirt
as products the
user may also like.
For example, here we recommend
other types of collared shirts.
But there are some
things to consider.
It's not just as easy as putting
some pictures in an email
and sending the email.
There are certain things we
need to take into account,
like product exclusion rules,
which are evaluated at runtime.
What a product's exclusion rule
could look like is you say,
in the email, you don't want
to show a product that's
on discount or out of stock.
Or maybe even you want
to show a product that's
recently come back into stock.
Since products
update constantly,
it's very important that
we have an accurate catalog
and don't show invalid
products in the email.
This requirement definitely
makes our service
a bit more interesting.
And we'll talk about how
we use our Product Update
Listener to keep our
product catalog fresh.
MARK HURWITZ: So a marketer's
decided to send an email,
and they create a campaign.
The campaign has an
audience and a template.
A template has blocks, which may
contain recommended products.
The template is mixed with
the audience query that
runs in BigQuery,
and with those, we
can generate the emails.
Products are then joined with
the audience in the query,
which means that any decisions
the template makes cannot rely
on anything that the
query is unaware of.
Generating audiences this
way is very flexible,
and we consider it to be
a competitive advantage.
But applying recommendations
at this stage is very limiting.
So you may be asking,
is this good enough?
On-site was a new
frontier for Bluecore
that forced us to
re-evaluate our architecture.
Latency became a primary
driver, not just bandwidth.
Audience generation
and personalization
are separate, which
means the templates are
limited to data appended to
the rows of the audience query.
We want to support templates
that are structurally dynamic,
rather than just
filling in blocks.
And that means either making
the audience query aware
of all of the decisions
that need to be made,
which is pretty difficult,
or allowing the template
to pull the
recommendations it knows
it needs at runtime,
on a per-email basis.
A/B testing is another example
of a personalized runtime
decision that's difficult
to make in the database.
Previously, we were copying some
recommendations into Datastore
to support these use cases.
And while Datastore is
great, this is really not
what it was made for.
And it got to be very expensive.
So we had to build
something new.
Pages on the web
start to feel slow
at 300 to 400 milliseconds,
and recommendations is only
part of the on-site
campaign process.
There's also generating
the template,
and translating all that
data to and from the browser.
So we gave ourselves
about 100 milliseconds
to do all the work
that we needed to do
on the recommendation side.
We want to be able
to serve about 50
million emails an hour.
And if you do a
little math, that
works out to 13,000
emails a second.
We targeted 20,000
emails a second,
because we figured that
would be enough headroom.
Doing product
filtering in the email
means that there must be
enough products returned
that the filters will be
run across all of them,
and there'll still be enough
to fill in the blocks.
That means sending more products
than are actually required down
into the templating engine.
We wanted to move
those decisions up
into the recommendation
service, so that we were only
returning the products
that we needed,
rather than returning too many.
Or potentially,
even worse, too few.
Supporting recommendations
via A/B tests
is vital, because
frankly, without testing
you can't improve.
And we want to do all
of this without spending
all of our money.
ALEXA GRIFFITH: So for
the naive implementation,
we want to change as
little as possible.
We know this probably won't
be good enough in the end,
but what it will do is it will
give us a good idea of what
areas we need to improve on.
So if we want to change
as little as possible,
how would we do it?
Well, we would choose to write
a GRPC service to communicate
with our templating
engine, and we
want to go ahead and
make use of the data
that we already have available.
Our recommendations data
already listed in BigQuery,
along with our products data
that comes from Datastore.
So this would be the minimum
we need for our service
to do runtime personalization.
The recommendation
service makes up
one of three parts
of personalization,
with the other two
being templating, which
comes from Datastore, and
the audience, which is just
all the people that
receive an email
and is stored in BigQuery.
The recommendation service
runs in Kubernetes' engine,
and is written in Go.
and the products data
lives in Datastore,
while the recommendations live
mainly in BigQuery, with some
copied into Datastore.
So now we've checked the
"as simple as possible" box.
But do we meet the "as powerful
as necessary" requirements?
Well, when considering
if our service meets
these requirements, we're going
to evaluate the recommendations
and products components.
Remember, we now have
to consider on-site,
or the recommendations
on the company's website,
as part of the requirements.
BigQuery is great for bandwidth,
but now latency is our problem.
We're failing to meet our
on-site latency requirements.
Even if we did export all
of our recommendations
from BigQuery to
Datastore, we still
might not hit our latency goals.
And keep in mind, for us, using
Datastore is expensive here.
But we can't blame a hammer
for being a bad screwdriver.
We just need the right tools.
So first, we're going
to discuss how we can
liberate our recommendations.
As I just mentioned,
BigQuery cannot be the source
of recommendations at runtime.
The latency is just too high.
So we looked into
Bigtable instead.
Why Bigtable, you may be asking.
Well, caching is not
a good option for us
because the specific
recommendation data for a given
recommendation type,
email, and namespace,
are often only read
once before they're
invalidated in the cache.
And a cache miss would
mean reading directly
from BigQuery, which
costs us in latency,
or Datastore,
which is expensive.
On the other hand,
Bigtable latencies
are around 15 to
20 milliseconds,
and better the
harder you hit it.
So if we consolidate
our data into Bigtable,
we can meet our
latency's requirements.
Our recommendations,
including events,
and our generated
recommendations from our data
science models, are
still stored in BigQuery.
Additionally, we
started generating
some of our recommendations
using data proc,
and these are stored in GCS.
We created a service
written in Go
that's a Kubernetes
task running in Airflow,
just to migrate and
consolidate our recommendations
data into Bigtable.
The GCS and BigQuery storage
API made loading data
into Bigtable fairly easy.
With a small Bigtable
cluster of just three nodes,
we're able to load,
read, and write
150,000 to 200,000
rows per second.
So now that we have
our data into Bigtable,
let's talk a little bit about
how we deal with our data
in Bigtable.
We have hundreds of namespaces,
but Bigtable has a 1,000-table
quota.
We can't have a
per-namespace table for each
of our recommendation models,
or we're going to quickly reach
that 1,000-table quota limit.
That's OK, though.
They don't call it
"Mediumtable" for a reason.
This is what Bigtable
was made for.
So instead, we
have a per-table--
we have a
table-per-recommendation model,
and our schema is the key
as the partner and ID,
which ID could be email.
And the value is a
list of product ID's.
So just to recap, this
is what we had before,
paying attention to the
recommendations coming
from BigQuery and
Datastore, which are now
consolidated into Bigtable
via our BigQuery-to-Bigtable
service.
And we picked up literally
seconds of latency.
So now that we've improved
the recommendation
component of the
service, are we good now?
Are we meeting our on-site
latency requirements?
Well, I mentioned previously,
on the previous slide,
that there are two areas
where we can improve
our recommendation service.
The recommendations
portion and the products.
Now that we've improved
recommendations,
we're still constantly fetching
products and Datastore,
causing it to burn a
hole in our wallets.
Additionally, we're failing the
on-site latency requirements
because of this too.
So we measured Datastore latency
from a GKE application written
in Python, and each
of the products
we fetched from Datastore are
around 2 kilobytes per entity.
We found that the Datastore
latencies aren't great.
They're about 45
milliseconds to get started,
and then an additional
4.2 milliseconds per key.
So like I said, not great.
But they aren't
totally disqualifying
for our use of Datastore.
MARK HURWITZ: Using
Datastore didn't leave us
a lot of headroom.
So if Datastore isn't going
to get us where we need to go,
we need to find something else.
What we need is a
latency smack-down!
Our objects are
about 2 kilobytes,
and so these are cachable.
We found Memorystore to be
about two orders of magnitude
faster than Datastore.
Fetching a single
key out of Datastore
cost about 50 milliseconds.
But Memorystore,
for the same load,
costs only 125 microseconds.
We're usually reading about
20 to 40 products per request,
so these numbers are more
realistic than you might guess.
Because Memorystore
is managed Redis,
it was easy to find
clients that support
all the features that
we need for performance,
such as pipelining.
We need to avoid the
calls to Datastore,
which means we need to have
a long TTL on our cache.
But Alexa already told us
the products are constantly
changing.
They're going in
and out of stock.
Prices are changing,
images are changing.
So we can't have a long TTL.
Our product can just
pipeline right to Datastore,
as it always has.
But now, it's also
notifying us of invalidation
by pushing product ID's
onto Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
We have a listener that reads
those ideas from Pub/Sub,
pulls the products
from Datastore,
and writes them to our cache.
You may be wondering, why do
we send ID's instead of just
sending the product bodies?
Well, the product
[INAUDIBLE] is concurrent,
so we can't know of any single
update as authoritative.
By sending ID's instead
of bodies on Pub/Sub,
we can guarantee that the
cache is eventually consistent,
rather than being potentially
inconsistent forever.
And we can have a very long TTL.
Datastore natively
returns protobufs,
and those come out to about
2 kilobytes, on average.
Now, we could have come up with
a new serialization format that
does everything that
Datastore's native serialization
format does, but there was
really no reason to do that,
because it's already doing it.
But with about 2
kilobytes per product,
and many, many
products, we'd end up
with a huge cache, which
is both expensive and slow.
So, how do we mitigate that?
The first thing is that we
don't update products that
aren't already in the cache.
Products get into
the cache by being
used in a marketing
product, which
means that the only objects
that'll be in the cache
are the objects that are
actually being sent out.
So if a partner of
ours happens to have
a catalog of a million products,
but they're only sending out
emails with 1,000
of those products,
we only have to have
1,000 in our cache.
The second thing we looked
into was compression,
but compressing
small items is hard.
Most compression algorithms
learn as they go,
which means if you're
compressing a book,
the first page is going to
compress significantly worse
than the 10th page
or the 100th page.
And with only 2 kilobytes,
there really isn't a lot of time
to learn.
By the time you get to
the end of the product
and finally know
how to compress it,
there's no more to compress.
So what did we do?
Well, first thing is that
we downloaded 1,858 products
from Datastore for
one of our partners,
which came out to
about 32 megabytes.
And we then tried to compress
them using gzip and xz.
And while the LZMA
compression of xz
is really too slow
for runtime, that's
kind of OK, because we're
really just testing here.
So we then found that we
were unable to do better
than 2-to-1 compression,
even with the very slow xz.
Well, that's not
really good enough.
So how good could it be?
Well, we took those
the same 1,858 products
and we tarred them all
together, effectively making one
big book, and compressed again.
And we found that gzip was
able to do better than 5-to-1,
and xz was even able to
do better than 8-to-1.
But we can't just tar
these products at runtime.
That doesn't make
any sense, because we
don't need all the products.
We don't know
which ones we need.
So we needed something else.
Fortunately for us,
Zstandard exists,
which allows you to train its
compression ahead of time.
They call this
"dictionary compression,"
and that's exactly what we do.
On a per-partner
basis, we download
a sample of the
products, compress them,
training the dictionary.
And then we store those
dictionaries into Datastore,
caching them in the
service as well.
So any time we read
or write a product,
we know exactly what
dictionary to use.
And the compression
is fantastic.
As you can see here,
Zstandard with dictionary
is better than 5-to-1, even on
small, 2-kilobyte [INAUDIBLE]..
There are other high-performance
and decompression algorithms,
such as Snappy and LZ4.
However, those don't offer
dictionary compression, which
as we've seen, is a big
factor with such small bodies.
As a reminder, this is
where we were before,
and this is where we are now.
We have products still stored
in Datastore, as we always have.
But now they're
being kept up-to-date
in a cache with our
Product Update Listener,
which is receiving invalidation
messages over Google Cloud
Pub/Sub.
The recommendation service
itself has a small LRU
cache with a short TTL, just
to keep the traffic-to-memory
stored down to a dull roar.
And we think we're finally
as powerful as necessary.
But, how to be sure?
The only way is to test it.
And fortunately for
us, the power of GKE,
this was pretty straightforward.
We were able to
deploy our service,
and to the attacking client,
into Google Kubernetes Engine.
And we could then scale both
the service and that client
with a single command.
The entire run, including
re-scaling the components,
was completely
scripted and hands-off.
And how did we do?
Well, we did pretty well.
With 16 two-core pods
running the service,
we were able to pull between 56
and 60 kilohertz, while still
staying within our
latency budget.
And we hit our target of 20
kilohertz with just four pods.
Yes, we are finally as
powerful as necessary.
Now that this code
is out in production,
well, changes need to be made,
and we need to live with it.
One thing that we do a lot is--
when changes are made,
we'll deploy a canary
into Kubernetes.
That allows us to validate
that the new code doesn't
have a regression, in terms
of correctness or performance.
And then once that's
proven, we can scale it up
to the rest of our pods.
Logs are exported automatically
from GKE into the BigQuery,
and so we've got a one-stop
shop for when we need
to look and see what happened.
And we're exporting all
of our metrics to Datadog.
And because this is
a production service,
we've got PagerDuty to wake us
up in the middle of the night
if something catastrophic
should happen.
So, what have we got?
Well, recommendations
are being written
to BigQuery and
Google Cloud Storage,
as they always have been.
But now they're being copied
into Google Cloud Bigtable.
Products are stored
in Datastore, again,
as they always were, but are
now being cached in Memorystore
and kept up-to-date using
invalidation triggered
through Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
Our clients hit us using
either protobuf over HTTP/1.1,
or gRPC over HTTP2.
And the whole thing is deployed
into Google Kubernetes Engine.
I'd like to thank you
all for listening,
and thank you to Google for
giving us the opportunity
to speak to you today.